when President Trump announced his plans
to move the u.s. embassy from Tel Aviv
to Jerusalem it is time to officially
recognize Jerusalem as the capital of
Israel he reversed decades of consensus
about the status of Jerusalem the
announcement sparked massive protests
among Palestinians and throughout the
Muslim world here are five things to
know about Jerusalem and why it's so
contentious number one both Israelis and
Palestinians consider Jerusalem their
capital Israel has controlled West
Jerusalem since 1949 during the six-day
war Israel captured East Jerusalem and
annexed that half of the city but the
international community considers East
Jerusalem occupied territory in 1980
after Israel passed a law declaring a
united Jerusalem their capital the
United Nations condemned the annexation
Palestinians want to divide the city and
make East Jerusalem the capital of a
future Palestinian state while Israelis
want a unified Jerusalem to be their
capital number two
Jerusalem is central to the peace
process during peace process
negotiations for the Oslo Accords the
issue of Jerusalem was initially set
aside to avoid D railing the talks in
2000 during a new round of negotiations
talks were upended when the leaders of
Palestine and Israel disputed who would
control the maze of tunnels under
Jerusalem number three
violence is not new in the holy city
control of Jerusalem has been a trigger
for violence many times in the past the
contested area of East Jerusalem is home
to some of the holiest sites in the
world
for Jews and Muslims it is the site
where Judaism's two sacred temples once
stood and the site where the Prophet
Mohammed ascended to heaven the trouble
is that the sites for Muslims and Jews
exist on the same land there's a
precarious power share in place Israeli
officials control who has access to the
complex but Muslims have religious
control inside
juice can enter but aren't allowed to
pray instead they use the western wall
the Second Intifada began in 2000 when
then opposition leader Ariel Sharon
visited the Temple Mount to assert
Israel's right to the complex
Palestinians protested and were met with
tear gas and rubber bullets the violence
lasted five years and killed over 3,000
Palestinians and nearly 1,000 Israelis
with thousands more wounded
more recently Israel set up metal
detectors to enter the complex which
Palestinians say restricted access to
the holy site sparking a new round of
protests and violence number four no
countries have embassies in Jerusalem in
the early 70s sixteen countries had
embassies including the Netherlands
Costa Rica Colombia but after the UN
Security Council condemned the
annexation of East Jerusalem in 1980
member states left now Jerusalem only
has consulates the US would be the first
country to have an embassy back in the
city number five
the US has avoided the embassy move for
decades though Congress passed a law to
relocate the US embassy to Jerusalem
more than 20 years ago the law includes
a loophole that allows the president to
delay the relocation for the sake of
national security
every sitting president Clinton Bush
Obama has used this power and signed the
waiver every six months president Trump
signed the waiver in June 2017 and again
in December 2017 but also signaled he
would begin the process of moving the
embassy from Tel Aviv to Jerusalem
president Trump was careful not to call
Jerusalem the undivided capital of
Israel but opposition to Trump's
declarations and the proposed embassy
move grows Muslim countries worldwide
urged the recognition of East Jerusalem
as the capital of a future Palestinian
state in Jerusalem tensions are higher
than usual Palestinian militant group
Hamas has started launching rockets into
Israel from Gaza and calling for a third
intifada
Israel has arrested Palestinians and is
clamping down on protests and as lines
are drawn and the fight for Jerusalem
intensifies the future of
israeli-palestinian stability is once
again at risk
[Music]
[Music]